depuis des jours il a tenté de résister
mais le scandale d'initiation
inappropriée dans le monde du hockey au
pays a fini par le faire tomber après 37
ans comme commissaire de la Ligue junior
majeur du Québec Gilles courtaud a
finalement remis sa démission avec effet
immédiat dans une lettre publiée sur son
compte Twitter l'homme de 65 ans
explique que les événements récents ont
éprouvés sa famille et que persister
serait de l'entêtement les élus à Québec
attendaient cette décision
avec avec ce qui est arrivé la semaine
dernière c'était c'était inévitable en
commission parlementaire Gilles Courtot
a affirmé sous serment que les actes
d'initiation violentes telles que sur
rapporter ailleurs au pays ne s'était
pas produit dans sa ligue la déclaration
d'une victime à toutefois démontré le
contraire les parlementaires voulaient
donc l'entendre à nouveau j'avais
l'impression que son premier passage
devant nous avait été assez
catastrophique puis en plus Moïse il
avait certainement oublié certains
détails la ministre responsable du sport
Isabelle Charest n'était pas disponible
pour des entrevues nous entendons
travailler en étroite collaboration avec
son successeur et critel pour nous
assurer que le développement de nos
jeunes se fasse dans un contexte
sécurité les amateurs du sport sont
partagés Porto il va être au courant de
ces choses-là à travers de la Ligue moi
ça me surprend parce qu'il mérite pas ça
le nouveauté aussi
à la jeunesse j'ai le Courteau qui est
ses fonctions plusieurs mois avant sa
retraite prévue en 2024 malgré son
départ le Parti québécois insiste
toujours pour l'entendre une deuxième
fois en commission parlementaire reste à
voir s'il y aura consensus à l'Assemblée
nationale ici Charles Dumoulin
Radio-Canada Montréal